Food and Drug Administration proposing a
big change for more inclusive blood
donation this is a big deal if approved
it would allow gay and bisexual men to
donate blood it is now reporter Laura
negretti shows us what this means and
talks with someone already ready to give
blood
when people come out and say we need
blood help us we're able to heed that
call and help again we know that we're
at a critical shortage of blood and we
want our lgtbq brothers and sisters to
know that they're able and we welcome
them and we want them to be able to
donate and this proposal could be a game
changer for blood donations it would
allow bisexual donors in monogamous
relationships it does away with the
current three-month abstinence
requirement for men who have sex with
men instead donors will be screened
through a questionnaire surrounding
sexual behavior according to the
American Red Cross it's pleased the FDA
has proposed to determine Blood Donor
eligibility using a gender inclusive
individual risk-based assessment
regardless of sexual orientation if the
change does go through Blood Bank
shelves like this one at a local
American Red Cross could look a lot more
full I spoke to James Franklin excited
about the opportunity to donate again it
makes me happy the last time I was able
to delightful I was in the mid 90s and
that's because of restrictions the FDA
found all blood donations from gay men
during the AIDS epidemic blood banks
already test blood for infectious
diseases and will continue to do so one
of the last discriminatory issues that
we have to deal with and to become equal
members of the community
so the FDA process actually allows 60
days for public comment on the draft
guidance we'll have that link for you on
our website